[Music]
straight ahead
all on crime daily harvey weinstein
scores a legal win
but asks a judge to halt proceedings in
another case the convicted movie
producer
says his health has dramatically
declined and a former
fbi criminal profiler gives us an inside
look into the mind of a serial killer
what we can learn about a violent
extremist behind more than 20 murders
right at an early age with the abuse he
was yet he was destined to admit
crimes plus the defense rests for an
ohio woman accused of murder
but will the jury believe her story law
and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
convicted sex offender and former movie
producer harvey weinstein
may be coveted free but his legal
battles continue
one of the women accusing weinstein of
sexual assault was
has withdrawn his her lawsuit a new york
federal judge
ruled that the woman needed to publicly
identify herself
using her real name in order to go
forward the woman who filed as jane
doe alleged that weinstein
groped her at the 2007 khan film
festival
and lured her into sex acts in toronto
and los angeles
weinstein is currently serving a 23-year
sentence for rape and assault charges
he also is facing additional criminal
charges in los angeles
and has a number of lawsuits against him
his defense attorney is requesting a
pause and proceedings in one of his
civil cases
citing his declining health joining me
now is harvey weinstein's civil attorney
enron ansari
imran always a pleasure to have you here
thanks for joining us
thank you brian so imran i've looked at
these motions i've i've got them here
i've gone through them all
the gist of them seems that you wanted
the alleged victim jane doe
to publicly name herself but i'm seeing
a lot of detailed descriptions as to
when and where she say these allegations
occurred
los angeles toronto
france isn't it just simple to turn to
your client and say hey do you know who
this person could potentially be
based on all these names and defend him
based on that and you don't need her
to publicly name herself
ryan well it's not as simple as that and
and the reason why we were seeking for
uh this particular plaintiff or any
plaintiff
who has come forth with allegations of
this kind against my client
to name herself publicly is because
there's a constitutional favor and the
court's favor
a more open proceeding and a defendant
really has a right
to know uh the identity of their accuser
uh to be able to put them to their
burden if you will
in the court of law whether you be a
criminal case or a
civil case and that's really what we
were looking for here
um this individual has made allegations
against harvey weinstein
they're rather salacious allegations
against harvey weinstein
and if she is going to use the court
system to bring this lawsuit
we you know based on precedent based on
uh what the courts have favored and that
is an open and fair proceeding
we're seeking for her to file that
complaint under her real name
and the judge in this case agreed with
us she ordered this
plaintiff to file her complaint under
her true identity
uh she did not do that instead she
voluntarily dismissed
her complaint against harvey weinstein
um and i think that's important
i totally get that it's a confrontation
clause issue and i support that but from
what i'm reading she was willing to give
her name
to weinstein's team and weinstein just
not to the public so why push for more
you would have known the name
and sort of weinstein because brian
listen
it's not it's it's a a public perception
um a it's the access to the courts and
and and open proceeding
and b it really is a
a message if you will to those who are
going to bring these claims
against harvey weinstein that they
should do so openly and under their real
name
why brian because listen he's not
an easy target we don't want people to
think that harvey weinstein
is an easy target if you think that you
can bring a civil lawsuit against him
just because
he's harvey weinstein just because he's
been convicted of this crime
well no if you're going to do that you
should do so openly
if you feel confident about your claims
you should do so
in an open proceeding and that is sort
of a message
that we want to get across here that if
you're going to bring a claim
listen he's not a sitting duck he's not
an easy target
he's going to defend these claims
whether they be the civil claims
or the criminal claims in in los angeles
he's not giving up he's vested in his
defense
both criminal and civil and he's going
to defend himself against these
allegations
i hear you now as i said iran this is
not the only case this one got dismissed
as you said she voluntarily dismissed
the case by withdrawing there's another
case where you're
saying that you want the judge to pause
because of declining health
and that case has a little bit more um
information or background
that involves ali casano what can you
tell us about that case and this
proceedings like going forward
sure brian that's the case about ali
canosa versus harvey weinstein
we've also similarly filed a motion in
the case of geiss
at all i say at all because there's a
string of plaintiffs
in that case to stay the deposition of
harvey weinstein and why
are we seeking that well it's twofold
it's a
because he's uh in a state of decline
health-wise
and that was reported quite
significantly this week
brian you heard about him having a fever
he was tested for covid
that wasn't a positive test but
regardless
he's not well he is suffering from a
multitude of health conditions
uh and and we have brought that to the
attention of the court
thanks imran and now to terry austin
with news involving lions
tigers and the feds a netflix star is
accused of inhumanely treating animals
and this time it's not the tiger king
himself
federal authorities say jeff lowe
violated endangered species act
by illegally taking possession and
transporting animals at his oklahoma zoo
low and his wife lauren took over the
zoo from the tiger king joe exotic in
2016.
lowe closed the zoo in august and agreed
to pay
100 000 in delinquent state sales taxes
the complaint accuses low of
inadequately caring
for grizzly bears and ring-tailed lemurs
as well as burning tiger carcasses
and in other animal related news a pair
of quick thinking and creative emergency
responders
are being credited with saving a
family's dog the atlantic highlands
police department was called out to a
fire
at a family's home in august smoke was
coming out of the windows and they knew
some furry friends
were trapped inside one of the patrol
men moved scaffolding from the side of
the house
while a fire chief grabbed a yard chair
to help reach the second floor story
porch
where the dog was waiting body cam video
captured the rescue
we got a man just get ready for the pass
man
you got that you want to grab that hold
it sturdy
[Music]
i'm gonna pass down to you all right bro
[Music]
i got him i got him
what a great rescue still ahead on long
crime daily a woman on trial for murder
wrestles with the idea
of taking the stand and later hear from
one of the top criminal profilers
of a serial killer's reign of terror
when we come back
[Music]
joseph paul franklin was a prolific
serial killer who shot hustler publisher
larry flint and targeted victims across
the country
based on their race he died by execution
in 2013.
long crimes anjanet levy has an
exclusive interview with the fbi
profiler who's written a book
about helping to nab franklin
john douglas spent many years as an fbi
agent and he's credited
with creating the art of fbi profiling
he has written books in the past and he
has a new book out
entitled killer shadow it's about joseph
paul
franklin a prolific serial killer john
douglas thank you so much for joining us
oh thank you thanks for having me so
tell us about
uh the latest book and why you decided
to focus on
joseph paul franklin goes to paul
franklin was really going to be a
make a break case for me as a as a young
fbi agent at the fbi academy
developing this new concept called
criminal profiling
and the fbi heads and headquarters were
watching from a distance
they heard about the research i was
doing with serial murderers
around the united states and the cases
that i was doing for local police
but i've only been doing it for about
three years and then one day
in october 1980 i got a call from a dave
pole he's a supervisor in the civil
rights division he said john
we know you've been doing his research
we have this offender named joseph paul
franklin
we don't know where he is he just
escaped now from a uh from a jail in
kentucky
he's killed over 20 people do you think
you think you can
help help us out and i said really i
said
i don't know i said i'll give it a whirl
so they said come on up to headquarters
i went up to headquarters got
boxes of material brought that back down
to quantico
but before i left they even said hey
john if you threw up this one here
you could be working uh cattle wrestling
cases in butte montana
so uh you know do a good job did you
just see a pattern there or
what what kind of led you to bring him
together
as the suspect in all of these killings
yeah well who
who put together really was the uh the
fbi lab and state labs around the
country that
put put it all together through
forensics uh
so it wasn't that because that's what
made it so difficult
because you look uh you look for the the
mo was different
in every one of these cases the
signature was the the victims
he was talking targeting a racist couple
uh interracial couple they could say he
was
targeting dude coming out of the
synagogue
so it was very very it was a very very
complex case to assess
so by looking at my role and goal was
was to see what our
strengths and weaknesses they didn't
know where he was in the united states
and what i said was
he'll be in mobile and uh i went out
and i told him i told him why the the
rationale behind it was
is that this didn't add with nobody his
only accomplishment really in life with
the
crimes that he perpetrated uh
particularly bank robberies in the
mobile area
plus he was married twice and every time
he was 17
married a girl 16 divorced after four
months
he then at 27 marries a 16 year old girl
has a child
a child in mobile alabama so like a
homing pigeon
i felt that he'd be gravitating back to
mobile
as well as to um to different blood
donor uh uh
places where he would sell his plasma
and sure enough
notes those days was with teletype
wasn't uh
emails and that kind of stuff and the
teletype goes out
the agent shark the mobile office says
john he says
we spotted him in mobile you're right he
said why
banker's savings alone i i don't know i
picked the city i can't tell you it's
like
what what's the address of a killer you
know if you when you do a profile you
can't provide that
and so got that information and they
flooded the blood banks and
and surveilled the bank's uh uh
savings and loans and that he was
spotted leaving mobile and ended up down
in florida and we caught him on a
blood bank what do you want readers to
kind of take away from this book
when i go around public speaking is
they're interested in the
type of people that perpetrate these
crimes and they think that it's very
very
you know out of the ordinary out of the
ordinary the backgrounds of these people
uh the fbi today uh need the public
to be looking for signs of potential
problems
on individuals uh because they don't
now you have the internet you know you
have the internet
we don't you don't have to meet in some
basement somewhere like the klan did in
the
nasty party you can inspire this hatred
over the incident
and not everyone belong to this group
will commit violence
but someone will observe action someone
will
out there the general public someone
where this person has become obsessed
with violence okay obsessed with hatred
or black minorities of any any
day of color and and it's important and
so they'll be able to recognize some of
these indicators here
unfortunately you can't you can't stop
somebody
like like franklin there'll be more
franklins
well john douglas author of killer
shadow i can't wait to read it i'm
really excited to dig into it thank you
so much for talking with us today
it was a great honor and we wish you the
best with this new book oh thank you
thanks angela thank you very much
john douglas's book is available in
stores and online
when we return an army veteran killed
delivering a pizza
who's really behind the murderous plot
plus a jury's verdict for a former
baseball player convicted of killing
three people
with his own baseball bat the life or
death decision after the break
a former pro baseball player will spend
the rest of his life behind bars
for murdering three people with a
baseball bat brandon willie martin was
convicted of slugging to death
his father his uncle and a security
system installer
prosecutors say he killed them in a fit
of rage after losing his 800 thousand
dollar contract
but his defense says he has
schizophrenia and had a long history
of mental illness it was up to the jury
to decide if he should face the death
penalty for the triple murder
or life in prison here was a verdict
of entitled action as the defendant
brandon willie martin
fix the penalty under counts one two and
three of the amended information
as life imprisonment without the
possibility of parole for the murders of
barry swanson
michael lee martin and ricky lee
anderson
all right i'll have terry austin and
mike horobonics with me terry let's
start with you get right to the media
potatoes
was this the right decision by the jury
i do think it was the right decision
brian you know we heard medical
testimony that he suffered from
schizophrenia
and several witnesses including his own
brother testified that
martin was actually hearing voices so
and you know i think the the main point
here is that anyone who can take a
bat and brutally murder three people one
of them
being his father who was in a wheelchair
obviously
has some mental illness so i do think a
life sentence was appropriate versus
death
and let's hope that he gets the medical
treatment that he needs while he's in
prison
now mike we're talking about mental
health disorders here but no doctor
actually took the stand
to provide a medical diagnosis how do
you think the jury came to the
this decision without it well i think it
was very strong and what really spoke
volumes to the jury was the fact the
brother testified on his behalf
and i believe his mother testified as
well on his behalf
and i think the jury really didn't need
expert testimony they saw a family
that have lost enough lives and whether
he killed that well he did kill them
the question remains is i think the jury
said do we really need to have this
family lose another member
so there's a little bit of irony here
exactly yeah and i think that came the
right
right decision thanks mike and when we
come back a pizza order ends in a
woman's strangulation
we take you inside the courtroom where
past and present lovers
point the fingers at one another stay
with us for capital gavel coverage
i'm dan abrams and this is the lawn
crime network
the only 24 7 network with expert legal
analysis
and gavel to gavel live trial coverage
watch the law on crime network today
[Music]
the defense has arrested in a trial of
ohio woman accused of murder
in a deadly love triangle prosecutors
say erica stefanko placed a fake pizza
order out of domino's
to lure ashley biggs to her death biggs
was a retired army veteran
and worked as a pizza delivery driver
stefanko's ex-husband chad cobb
pled guilty to murdering biggs and later
helped to implicate stefanko
police discovered the victim's body
after a neighbor spotted her car
in a cornfield the defense called the
defendant's
husband sorry as their only witness in
an effort to point the finger
back at chad cobb stefanko left cobb for
her
for his friend after he was arrested for
murder
he was extremely frustrated with the
situation and that he
can't believe that it was happening
more or less did he ever threaten ashley
uh not that i know to her person
but uh definitely in conversation
all right and what did he say about that
threat
uh he needed her gone
what else was he gonna do to her uh he
made a comment that when it was all said
and done that he wanted to keep her
skull as a trophy
did you say that more than once i
believe he said it on at least two
separate occasions
did he say this in your presence yes he
did
stephanco's husband also said cobb
called him shortly after the murder
and said quote i f'd up and asked to
bring him a change of clothes
on cross prosecutors asked why he only
revealed this
information for the first time on the
stand
if i had been asked at any point before
these last few weeks i would have no
problem divulging that information
do you think that information is good
for erika stefanko
i think that information is the truth
ma'am okay
and you didn't want to come forward and
say
chad said he did this
use it in a singular not they or he
you just you kept that to yourself until
i was asked about it man
strong testimony terry it appeared the
defendant was going to testify
then changed her mind walk us through
how that all plays out in real life
well we don't know exactly what was said
between the defendant and her attorney
but here's
what we do know we know she has a right
not to take the stand and that cannot be
used against her
we know that they took an hour and a
half to talk to determine
whether or not she wanted to go on the
stand and at the end of the day she
decided no i'm not going to testify and
the judge confirmed
that she knowingly voluntarily and
intelligently made that decision so
that's all we really need to know
corbonics you've been here before game
time decision the trial is about to end
are you going to put on your witness or
not do you feel like this was the trial
that needed a defendant to testify
though
absolutely not i feel this child needed
not to have any defense put forward i
didn't think that was a good witness
the this trial needed to put the
investigation
on trial saying if you investigators and
police officers were so reliable and did
such a thorough investigation
why was this man able to plead guilty to
this murder
without her ever being mentioned until
years later
when the person who pled guilty sent the
letter to try to better his position in
life imprisonment
and now you're asking this jury to
believe those same
investigators and law enforcement who
did the investigation
to say they could prove this beyond a
reasonable doubt when they couldn't
closest to when it happened terry
there's a lot of bombshells in this case
what would you point to being the
biggest bombshell in terms of testimony
that you heard
definitely cobb testifying first that he
did it and then on cross saying no
i didn't have anything to do with it so
that was a bombshell i think to
everyone involved mike would you agree
in terms of bombshell is that a pretty
big one
yeah you couldn't even hear it after
that one went off exactly
mike and terry thanks for joining us and
thank you all for joining us all on
crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you